it's this disease that's taking over
everybody and it's like i think the
future belongs to people who are just
gonna pay attention to the way the world
actually manifests what actually is
interesting
uh what life is actually like and tell
those stories and that's gonna win the
day
you're right you're so right that's
what's going to win
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
so hello everybody i am here with neil
degrade people who watch my channel have
seen him around he is
the head of the band dirk robbins but he
is much more than that we're here to
talk about a new movie that he's putting
together called the queen of the night
very excited about it it's like a modern
fairy tale and so i'm really looking
forward to talking about that with him
thank you for having me on always a
pleasure
um you know people might notice right
now that today's video is in black and
white um and that is by no accident or
technical error we have
as a band we've always done concept
records but now we've decided to add a
visual component a stronger visual
component to what we're doing and we're
making a silent film it felt like the
perfect way to
oh um
oh create a story a visual story that we
could put our music to so it felt like a
no-brainer we had the right story and
and here we are it's called queen of the
night
yeah so tell us a little bit about the
the mood of it because there's something
it it has an old-timey uh sense to it
you know it's a silent film
it uh it's using
it's using kind of these classic effects
even that look kind of old-timey um but
there's something about it there's
something about it that's very rich in
terms of visuals that you were able to
create very simply you know that this
movie is not costing you a fortune
either all of this is an interesting
idea or solution for kind of modern
movie making or making stories today
oh yeah oh my gosh give me a lot to
comment on right there um let's talk
about silent films quick quickly uh you
know it's there's early era in films and
silent films generally at first were
just like they're trying to bring a play
to
life
and things were shot like they were on a
stage cameras wouldn't move uh actors
were coming in and out of the frame off
stage on stage and the props were
generally like two-dimensional so i
wanted to keep an aspect of that when i
did it like uh but i also there's
something very tiring about silent films
if you try to pull one up on youtube
that are like that it's like oh this is
cute but gee an hour long of this you
know
is like uh okay if you don't have that
attention anymore like when you just
want to do a puppet show for you and it
just doesn't end you're like there's
gotta be you want me to watch you play a
game you're making up on the fly so uh i
didn't want to do that because i'm not a
huge fan of a lot of silent films i've
seen i really love the movie metropolis
um the cabin of dr uh caligari i love
the old nose ferratu i'm a huge fan of
those but the versions i've seen have
been fully orchestrated
i think imagine back in the day from
what i've heard it would be
uh
quite an event to go see one of these
films premiere or at a larger theater
because there would be a full orchestra
there doing it live and so if you'd like
to see an orchestra normally great but
if you want to see an orchestra with a
story in a movie well now you're talking
next level so uh i wanted to capture
more of that i wanted to feel alive and
exciting i didn't want to be fatiguing
um i did when you're talking about the
old-timey effects like uh we'll show a
clip in a minute but um there is a
little of that jitter and dust speckle
and stuff that would appear in the film
but we didn't we wanted to do enough so
you got it but we didn't want to do so
much that you were tired of seeing that
so we've tried to ride that line of
creating that nostalgia that sense of
familiarity without the same sort of
fatigue that accompanies that look and
feel
the film's done in an expressionistic
style uh which was really popular in in
that time is that people were not going
for realism they were but they wanted to
capture real emotion so there's a
dreamlike quality to the film and it's
imagery things are laid out where they
feel three-dimensional but it also could
be
it also could be like a diorama the way
things are someone might be pulling the
clouds along in the background uh you
know on a string and
we've tried to do some uh where even
when we're using computers to
incorporate some of that human analog
era error in the process so
that's part of queen of the night and
for people on who follow this channel i
think that they're going to
without explanation be able to start
digging into some of the symbolic
content yeah so the way you're releasing
it is through episodes or you're putting
out the different episodes i have the
chance you know because of my special uh
relationship with neil to kind of follow
the the thing from the beginning and
know the whole story and kind of get a
sense of this really powerful uh modern
fairy tale but for the first for the
first episode we're gonna kind of be
introduced to these main characters and
also uh get a sense of what is the sim
what is the symbolic structure it has to
do with the moon the feminine the light
the darkness and so maybe tell us a
little bit about what it is that you're
trying to explore in this story
okay well
uh one of the problems is when i talk
about any of these things it the way
we'll talk about it right now is not the
way it comes to me yeah an image will
come to me and then i'll start like
almost question questioning it like why
am i seeing this right now so um pretty
much every one of my stories i've done
or concept record starts with a singular
image and
then i like i've become like an
inquisitor of that image it's like why
are you there why are you holding that
why you why are you standing in the spot
why are you crying why are you you know
um why are you on top of this building
why are you on this mountain those type
of things so and then i i just slide
things around and then suddenly things
will uh fall into place um very quickly
and
and before i really knew what i was
doing with this uh when i go back and
look at my older work it still feels
like now that i understand like some of
the symbolic content and story a little
more explicitly it still was already
fitting even though i didn't even know
really what i was doing or what i was
talking about i just had an intuition so
uh what we're about to talk about here
is not why the story was created in fact
that's why um we could share this with
people i brought jonathan in uh pretty
early on in 2021 when once i had the
story and i wanted to tell it to you
because uh i didn't want to think about
some of those elements but i thought
since you weren't a creator
i would do that and that you would
basically slap me back in line
um but that's not really what happened
uh i think we had a really good
collaboration on this is that i shared
the story with you and it was like it
was more of a yes and it was more yes
we're like this is awesome hey what
about this but like it's so much of it
was so right the intuition was so right
so you you added layers and you
explained things to me i didn't even
notice like because i i didn't want to
i didn't want to spoil it by
explicitly adding
um analogous or allegory to the content
or um typology on purpose i didn't want
to do it on purpose i think i absorbed
the world through this typological lens
and more of the symbolic lens and so
things when i tell them back they come
out that way
so um i feel like i don't have to try
that and when i do now i'm starting to
um i guess impose
a desire for the story on it um you know
so i don't want to do that um so yeah we
when i when i handed this over to you we
talked about a number of things um
symbolism of the moon uh masculine and
feminine symbolism
and when we talk about masculine
feminine symbolism we're not talking
about modern stereotypes about
differences between men and women we're
talking about the way those things
reveal themselves over time in mythology
um and in stories so
uh i think that was uh that was fun to
do i really loved your insight you
pointed out so many things to me um
that never would have occurred to me uh
in the story so i think that people who
the people who
watch this
watch this who follow your channel are
going to get an added
layer that's just going to be implicit
to the general public i
i generally don't like
explaining things to people yeah in the
past like because i mean once it's there
i kind of understand why
i wrote it you know with dead horse it
dealt with the pandemic it dealt with
this sort of
uh totalizing system that was coming
that they were going to kind of give in
exchange for pleasure
for um
in exchange for pleasure for this like
control and manipulate yeah over you so
um
and so you know by the time that thing
was coming out we were about to hit the
pandemic in 2020 so that's so amazing
that i still can't get over that like
that that the the the whole album was
like a prophecy that just played itself
out in front of us it's pretty amazing
well i mean i i don't think it might
that is as that unique though i saw a
lot of things like that like i kept
things kept coming to my attention that
had just happened in different shows
that were buddy was sort of people with
a certain type of intuition were already
on to where things were heading yeah and
um it's just like you know if i picked
up a you know
a rock and threw it towards a window
before that rock hit the window we would
all kind of know it's about to hit the
window yeah exactly because you can see
the momentum the velocity and the
trajectory so um i think one of the best
ways to talk about why i don't want to
talk about things too much uh when it
comes to specific story is an image i
think i've shared this with you before
but it is from peter pan and in the
beginning of peter pan uh
it's obviously like a meta fairy tale in
the sense where it does a lot to explain
itself to an audience like films
generally wouldn't or fairy tale
generally would even you have never
never land yeah you have a lot of these
more explicit structures overlaid on a
fairy tale type story and one of those
happens right in the very beginning
because it seems like the author whether
they did this um
intentionally or just by intuition uh
understood what they were getting into
with the story where peter pan appears
in person without a shadow he's not he's
not yet a part of this
universe that
wendy lives in and now her at this
coming of age story she she needs to
she needs to try on this childish idea
she's about to leave behind she needs to
experience like in his full totality
like what she's when she leaves the
nursery what she's really leaving behind
and uh
so
it's her job to stitch the shadow onto
peter pan's foot and that hurts like he
doesn't like it right it's so there's
this aspect of where i don't want to put
too many stitches in peter pan's foot
um
so people can kind of just absorb the
story for themselves yeah to some degree
so i hope that was but i think that the
process that you're talking about like
in terms of the way you wrote it you
know this is actually the way that i'm
telling people always because i i have
people writing me or ask me all the time
you know i'm trying to write a story and
try to put symbolism into it
and they then they just they just they
just hit a wall because they can't do it
which
is actually the they're
which is inevitable because you can't
think about symbolism and write
symbolically at the same time those two
are two different completely different
ways of being you have to
like you said i think the way you talk
about it where you have an image and
then you poke at the image and you turn
around it and you
you kind of nurture this intuition is a
much better way to do it and then once
you once you have something out there
then you can combat with
clippers and just kind of prune it a
little bit or re-adjust things slightly
so that they're more
they're they're they're more coherent in
terms of the structure but you don't
want to do that at the outset
yeah and again too like
i'm trying to like so let's just say
that something's supposed to be
beautiful i'm not i never try to make it
pretty i try to make it break my own
heart
um and it's just it's a it's a very
different reaction so like the idea of
trying to make something coherent
intentionally is that same thing you end
up with
you end up with pretty instead of
heartbreaking and
uh so
i don't know if that's just kind of an
adjacent analogy but uh so yeah i mean
my encouragement for artists who uh you
want to do that is you you ha it begins
with having to absorb the world
differently
and we've been lied to about what i
think in a lot of ways um in our
schooling and not that these things
aren't important but sort of the
scientific world
um this modern mindset of the things
that really matter are things you can't
touch taste and feel or you don't really
experience firsthand i think one of the
first videos i encounter with you is you
talking with um
your brother mature about uh
i don't even know how to say that in
french people um i can't pronounce it
matthew that's okay
okay so uh
um he uh
you you guys were talking about water
that when you drink water like like you
well that might have been coffee you
don't experience h2o
you experience cold and wet and like you
know we all we we have the problem with
hgo none of us have that in common we
don't know what that is or what it
really looks like or how to experience
it but and so that if we think of it as
h2o we're at a distance from each other
but if we think about it as something
cold and refreshing now we're oh i know
cold and refreshing you know cold and
refreshing now we're more connected yeah
so there's been this deep
personification of the universe itself
that has led people back to a point
where they don't really know how to tell
and embodied stories because the story
because they think the real important
facts are what we see at the bottom of a
microscope or at the end of a telescope
when none of those things can actually
be experienced and i believe have led to
sort of a modern insanity
about things that are right in front of
our face we can't see anymore we're
colorblind too because we prioritize
those things and we've intellectualized
those things as the most important
and so i think that that's something
also
that's there in the the queen of the
night because the queen the first
episode has to do with this encounter
like a
like an encounter
an encounter between an encounter with
something which is bigger than you like
something that is just overwhelming
let's say um and it's not it's not in
the it's not in the analytical mode
right it's like uh
you know imagine uh yeah like seeing a
god or seeing this and it has to do with
the fascination with the with the
feminine and the whole story has to do
with
this feminine image which is related to
light light and darkness to the moon to
the veiling to the unveiling um and so
maybe tell us a little bit about like
what it is about let's say feminine
imagery which you feel
needs to be explored or needs to be
touched on or it needs to be uh yeah
that we need to talk about the power of
it and not just in the modern sense
where it's like okay we're gonna make
more roles for women okay it's like oh
great cool there's so many cool
things to talk about what are we going
to talk about no we're going to give
them swords and superpowers and they're
going to punch things and
and act like jerks like the men do
except they'll be like heroes for acting
like jerks
i know that that's what i just said
there is probably like what is he even
talking about some people or they just
you know the hair stood up on the end of
their back and they started screaming uh
but into their backs i don't know like a
cat
so
um but i think that
really like uh
i think that just this idea of
supplanting what was um in the past male
with just embodied by female characters
like that can happen in stories right
obviously uh but it's not it's you're
missing so many great opportunities and
hopefully we've taken some of those
opportunities here in this story to show
the the power of femininity in
um you know a more coherent way within
how the universe actually manifests
itself um let's do a clip um i got a
little short clip here uh i want to
insert in the video um of a scene where
he first encounters this feminine spirit
at a very low dark place for this little
boy
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's talk about the moon because that
appears in the story this is one of
these examples of things that we we
can't see anymore or isn't obvious to
people okay so the moon
and the sun the sun is 400 times larger
than the moon roughly okay
um but guess what else like that you
know uh the sun is 400 times farther
away than the moon which makes them
appear
roughly the same size in the sky they're
like oh well that's pretty cool it's
like well what are the chances of that
right and these things are hard to
calculate because we're opposing uh
we've got a there's a lot of factors
involved and it has to do with human
perspective but it's a it's a really
rare occurrence that if the world
universe is populated by all types of
people
and different people on different
planets this would ever occur on ours so
um when things start to become rare to a
certain point you start to see
intentionality in it so i see the
intentionality all over the universe i
see with the thing i'm about to describe
we see i see everywhere
so the moon and the sun appear roughly
the same size of the sky so
why was it why did ancient people like
always refer to the moon in almost every
situation as like a feminine spirit and
the sun is a masculine spirit it's like
well um the moon happens to have a
day
phase and cycle and guess what like
women have you know matured women have a
like roughly 29 day cycle and
there's no evolutionary correlation
between those two things like there's
been study after study the last one i
could look up was they had
checked with 7.5 million women to like
report on their cycle
and if it correlated with the moon and
it will line up once in a while meaning
that some people will you know
have their cycle on a full moon or a new
moon or whatnot but um it's not they're
not uh there's no scientific reason why
these two things are the same now for
someone like me who sees meaning in the
universe i like okay this is a
discussion of like cosmic feminine
cosmic masculine
and so to
if you never thought about it before the
fact that we have these two like equal
sized things in the sky and one
exhibits an explicit feminine pattern
right and one uh
that is
i don't know that could could be
revelatory to someone you know now like
i i talk to people all the time about
these kind of things they're like oh my
gosh i never realized that just like
it's like this was obvious to everyone
you know
prior to
our modern way of thinking so and you
can under if you when you understand
also that that the moon waxes and wanes
and that it moves from light to darkness
and from darkness to light then
you can also understand so much of
the some of the mystery of feminine
symbolism in relationship to the to
those things that are hidden and
revealed you can imagine even uh you
know the idea of seduction as this
showing and hiding you know this
revealing but not too much you know you
don't want to you want to keep a mystery
uh in this in this relationship and so
you know this idea of the of the mystery
is is very much related to feminine
symbolism and always has been
yeah and you talk about this all the
time i haven't seen all your videos but
i've seen quite a few and you're talking
about this idea of unity and
multiplicity and
and during the day when there there's a
unity above
and then there's multiplicity below
because this light allows us to name and
identify things so that you you know you
don't walk around in daylight tripping
and stumbling and falling into holes
generally because these things are made
explicit and the night the opposite
manifestation happens there's
multiplicity above and then there's this
unity but the unity's within darkness
below where the ground becomes one thing
all this multiplicity becomes one thing
and all this
thing that was one opaque sky becomes
multiplicity at night
um
there's a real i guess you know it might
be the wrong analogy but a yin yang kind
of relationship yeah of course these two
things um and so i think that's so cool
and there's
there's a beautiful story that we
experience every day in that and it's
actually a way to govern between
order and chaos that appears in stories
if you can look at those two patterns
correctly um so
you're talking about there you also
talked about explicit and implicit um
because one of the things that happens
you know so let's say someone reads the
bible and they hear the word light and
they think of light as good and darkness
is evil and it's used that way but it's
also not used that way right so there
are um there are things that are kept
secret that are hidden from you that are
true there are um there are
um analogies like hiding under the
shadow of of god's wing like the shadow
being the thing that's needed um so i
talked about this uh i talked about this
in dead horse a little bit there's a
song called kings and queens
and it's talking about this mothering
structure of the city
[Music]
drifted away
and the city could not be saved
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as each selfish thing fought
[Music]
in their
[Music]
and um
i was always confused when i was a kid i
would hear these old movies and they
refer to someone who is very beautiful
is fair
and i'm like what does fair mean and it
was like it dawned on me and i wrote it
into the bridge of that song
and it's talking about the city and
though the line was in blinding light
she stands opaque her silhouette a
welcome break for tired eyes a resting
place and um you know if you're crossing
the desert and you're burning in the sun
and you see
um you see the outline of a city right
it's like oh my gosh this is that's
that's my salvation
yeah from the sun
from the sun from the sun
right it's like you're like oh the sun's
a good thing it's like it's not always a
great thing i mean you can you can in
life you can die by water you can that
you need to live you can die by sunlight
which you need for everything to live uh
so the world's a complicated place and
uh you know things aren't as polemic as
people make them out to be and really
fairy tales are awesome with that having
these sort of
ambiguous structures that depending on
how you approach them manifest as good
or evil
yeah i think that's that's a really
great thing in storytelling that's kind
of missed and i love those stories and i
think we've got a little of that in
queen of the night here
um yeah definitely we i mean i think
that
in in the story i mean i we don't want
to reveal the the plot or anything but
there really is this kind of encounter
this seductive encounter or this
fascination which
you know the you can say something like
the masculine tries to control or tries
to possess
you know and then ultimately it's like
no sorry man it's not as easy as you
think you know
yeah right well in two so like i mean
there's a lot of things that we we might
push back against the life like someone
like people accuse me of mansplaining
and i'm like you actually have a point
like when you're saying that like you
know i don't mean in a like way that
someone really doesn't know how to shut
you down so they make some sort of
impotent claim like okay boomer or you
know thanks for mansplaining that to me
uh you know i'm not talking about in
that sense but the idea that like
that negative symbolic masculine is this
idea to over define over explain
pull too far out you know
show something you know uh you know even
like even the world of science you know
uh there's a great essay by c.s lewis
called the abolition of man which
everyone who watches this channel should
read yeah um it's amazing but he talks
about that you know science today would
do something uh you know to a person
that they wouldn't have considered 100
years earlier doing to a turnip um
there's this over masculinization of
everything and wanting to pull apart and
aim for power um yeah so i have a
question what so with all these movies
because this is kind of a change for
for you in a way i mean because you were
mostly doing music for the for the large
part of your career you wrote a book was
it last year you were a fairy tale there
yeah that's a little experiment i did
it's called uh the three golden robes
and a story like i mean you've known me
long enough jonathan know like a story
pops in my head every day
and uh i was like let me just let me do
the practice of kind of
putting this into a visualization so
there's an artist named chad nuss um
who's done some work he's doing concept
art on queen of the night uh he's
fantastic he has his own uh comic called
the silence comics and
he uh
he illustrated it for me and chad's art
is amazing so like he made it worth
buying
um you can find that at
dirtportrobbins.com i think i have a
link to that somewhere if you want to
check it out or look at the art
so what are you so what are you what's
happening like where where are you guys
so all right so
here's the thing so i do music
the fun thing about music is it's it
manifests itself
in in a type of opposite from the way
life comes at us normally so
um when we go out into the world um we
see things before we see patterns right
the
patterns take
uh i guess a type of spiritual
discernment in the sense that they're
they're not something that
manifests in a moment it manifests over
time and so we have to see the pattern
um so life we see things first we see
patterns second music
is pattern first and it implies the
things so
uh beethoven's six symphony he was
trying to
musically describe this you know a
pastoral setting in the countryside or
uh you know the movies fantasia really
have a great explanation of of this
relationship between the visual and
music but that gives you an example of
sort of like the different
the different worlds and so
i uh i i wanted to bring the story and
farther i thought we had a good story to
do it visually and you mentioned that
we we have some constraints on that
story and how we're telling it visually
um because it's a silent film
and those constraints are really helpful
to me as a new director and someone who
wanted to really bring a fantastical
image images to life with rockets and
zeppelins and
uh moon space travel and uh you know not
a 50 million dollar budget yeah yeah so
um
so yeah like putting those constraints
on it allowed us to uh really not have
to compromise anything
and uh
tell me and have a window in which we
could tell that story where you didn't
feel like things were missing hopefully
hopefully
boast um so uh yeah that's what we're
doing so um it's gonna be interesting
for people who follow us in the past
because like our last record was a
little bit more modern
than the raven locks the record we had
done before that it had some more synth
elements and even like robotic voices
and uh still with a blend of classical
and i think even classic rock in there
uh but this one
we're going farther back in time we're
pulling from the romantic period we're
also you know as we go all farther along
in the story as things modernize you'll
start to throw in some ragtime and
elements like that but at first it
starts out you're going to have if
you're waiting for it like a you know a
slapping
pop or rock number you're not going to
get one right away in the story so
episode one the music's kind of somber
and it deals with uh you know some more
symbolic content
[Music]
my
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
three
[Music]
it's a risk i mean but
i don't know i kind of work outcome
independent i just do what i think
is
what i really want to do and then people
like it um so how do you want is this
something that the storytelling part
like is it something because that you
know we need good storytellers so is
this something that you are interested
in continuing to do like are you are you
oh absolutely i want to do it everywhere
i mean i want to collaborate with other
artists too because i have more stories
than i can put out and i really love and
i would love to find
um some people who can visualize those
um you know i just told you about one
right before we started our call and i
feel like that's a great story man i i
would love to see that happen it would
be wonderful so i'm watching eric
weinstein on joe rogan's podcast i went
back and watched this and he's they're
talking about how like
oh the world's been stripped of this
sort of mythological content and story
spirited content and religious content
and stuff and he's like now it's time to
fill it with what's really interesting
and rogan's like well what's really
interesting eric weinstein what does the
world need to be focused on and he's
like the octonians um i can't do an eric
weinstein impression and i think it
would be insulting if i tried so i'm
gonna just talk about it so the
octonians if you're not familiar or if
you haven't seen the episode do you know
what they are jonathan i have no idea
what that is there's this theoretical
number set
right and he starts to go off about this
theoretical number set and i was like
eric weinstein have you not met a normal
person do you know
do you ever have you ever fallen in love
or what like i'd what are you doing you
ever have a really good meal like have
you ever had a funny thing happen to you
that you retold later it's like this is
not where people are at so this is part
of the insanity though of the modern
world it's had this
dull dulling effect on storytelling um
you know well so many stories like
what's really happening is like though
the zombie invasion is just it's really
a biological element and here's the
here's scientifically why there's a
zombie in page it's like no that's not
why we're telling zombie stories because
because you know it's we're telling
zombie stories because
you know
everybody's a zombie
that's why we're telling zombies like
people just zombing around and you know
not even looking at up at their kids
when they come in the room everyone
that's where we that's where we're
afraid of zombies because you know the
conservatives think that uh there's too
many liberals in the world and they're
all coming to get them and they're going
to make them think their way and they're
going to take over their mind and then
the liberals think there's too many
conservatives in the world and they're
coming forward and they're going to take
over their mind they're going to force
them to you know into the hands maiden
tale uh
so uh that's what's
that's why we tell zombie stories
we're not telling we're not having a
discussion about biology um and so
i
um
that's for sure like what you're saying
is is great because one of the things i
thought from the right from the
beginning is like this whole
idw thing i was like this is not this is
gonna fail it's gonna fail because they
don't understand how the world actually
changes it's like i'm sorry to tell you
guys artists change the world not not
like computer programmers and not
scientists like in terms of
changes in the sense of what happens in
the world like you can make a technology
but the dream of the world comes from
the prophets and the artists and even in
the scientific revolution you can see
that that cyrano de bergerac's uh you
know uh voyage to the moon
precedes any scientific desire to go to
the moon right the the storytellers were
the ones you know the the the all the
imagery that happened in the 17th
century a lot of it was storytelling it
wasn't and so we need to
the the kind of idw type that wants to
kind of help restore something without
without art they're not gonna do
anything they're just gonna fizzle
people are alone and like everybody has
the same things going on they're waking
up at 3am in the morning and they are
just miserable and they they look to
film and they look to story
and it's arguing about politics i mean i
i i i followed russell brand years ago
because he had someone interesting on to
me and i pull up his channel now and all
he's doing is is covering american
politics i'm like this british comedian
it's like it's this disease that's
taking over everybody and it's like i
think the future belongs to people who
are just going to pay attention to the
way the world actually manifests what
actually is interesting uh what life is
actually like and tell those stories and
that's going to win the day
you're right you're so right that's
what's going to win there's no there's
no way around it because
at some point this kind of political
type storytelling is going to become so
crippling you know i mean it might get
worse for a while but you know in the
end
the good stories win it's just
inevitable because they're better
they're just have they just have more of
reality in them and so right so i think
that what you're doing with queen of the
night do you know what you've been doing
with drupal robbins you know is is great
i mean it's right in line i mean i'm
happy that we're kind of collaborating
on on a lot of these things because
it's uh i think it's an exciting time to
be honest i i even though it's kind of
like the worst time in a very dark time
at this
all at once that's an exciting time
because you know these little lights i
think can flicker in the
in the madness because they'll appear as
what they are you know i get a little
lost for words sometimes because i don't
know how to describe
what i think is really beautiful in a
way that people can hear it anymore and
so i kind of don't most of they just
make beautiful things i just that's all
i know that's all i can do is try to
make beautiful things and they're not
political and they don't hold like i
mean what you're talking about you're
saying hey like
it's nice to have someone or to have
people out there who are actually trying
just to tell stories because
i'm not i don't have an explicit like
proselytizing purpose in what i'm doing
at all i just i just take what comes to
me and put it out there and i think
that's that's the only way that me as a
person can make the anything better my
life better my family's life better um
because we're we get so focused on
trying to change the world it's like
that's just like that's too much for
anyone that's not something there's
something like really exciting also
about this time which is that
there's something also i this is how i
feel like you tell me if you're right
but there's something really exciting
about feeling like you're in on a secret
this is how i feel sometimes because
like let's say
i think that that your album dead horse
is just amazing like it's just a it's
just a it's just a great album without
any qualifier and but it's still kind of
not it's not like the most you're not
like the most famous band in the world
you know it's not like everybody knows
about dirt paul robbins um but that's
there's something about that which is
exciting because there's this thing
burgeoning there's this light kind of
appearing and a few people are able to
perceive it and you know like there's no
doubt about it you know that
this is moving towards the future
and a lot of the stuff you hear on the
radio the stuff you stream on netflix
you can feel like
this is just dying like it's just this
decrepit thing that is kind of
decomposing
and it's like okay so i have i can
perceive this light which is growing uh
not everybody can see it yet but it's
but it actually makes it somewhat
exciting to feel like you're in on
something
well i know i also have like weak
selfish reasons why i like to stay a
little under the radar too it's because
uh i like anonymity a little bit i mean
here i am in your channel and i'm
wearing this uh you know animal print
shirt this zebra print thing but man
like though it's
it's it's a world of sound bites i wrote
a song about this on dead horse called
sky writer
um because the world's turned into a
place where everything's everyone's a
sky writer anything i say there's going
to be something i didn't say that can be
held against me like there's always this
something in the negative space of what
i've just said where someone can make me
saying something i'm not
and
and the world's awful with that and so
like there's a part of me that's kind of
like yeah i'd be totally happy
to just
have enough of an income to keep making
art and then people find it when i'm
dead and so they can't
you know so they can't ruin my life like
that's a little weak and selfish of me
sometimes not very courageous but i have
like the the modern world has made me
like
i there's no nothing in me left that
would want to do this for celebrity like
there's it's not there it's like that's
that's hard that's like my biggest fear
is to be a celebrity i guess in any
capacity so i also revel in the sort of
anonymity of what we do that
uh there are people that it seems to
impact and really enjoy it and i'm like
happy like my gosh
keep it there just enough income for i
can keep making more for you but
no actually we do need people i don't
want to we do need people to share the
video when it comes out there there's a
stronger part of me that's like who
cares okay so they'll tear you apart
you're just gonna have to go let's feed
yourself to the wolves if you're going
to
you're going to want to manifest your
full potential so that's kind of what i
end up acting on i have all these subtle
fears but at the end of the day we
really need people to share this and
watch this and if you love it like you
know
let your friends in on it like that's
that's where that's our entire marketing
plan basically outside of like coming on
your channel coming onto your channel
and talking like a derek fiedler who did
a really great review of your brother's
book the language of creation and he get
a really great response to matthew
mcconaughey and joe rogan about the
burning bush on symbolism of that um
he's gonna he's gonna be doing uh
breakdowns of the episode for people in
the symbolic world who want to hear that
kind of thing so we can link to him but
uh yeah i'm not doing much to promote it
right now so and that's part of the
reason we didn't take it straight to uh
streaming services because it's actually
not that hard to get on streaming
services but i think netflix has like 15
000
movies in their catalog so you can get
into this catalog and make no money
and pay money on the outside to
advertise to get people to go watch it
on their platform and i'm like that's a
great starting point
so right now we're kind of relying on
everybody to be like
to absorb this maybe um
we have a patreon channel like i mean
patreon account if they want to give us
some money there that's also helpful for
the post production because otherwise
i'm paying out of pocket um
so uh to get this done but yeah we're
going to be releasing the episodes over
the next few months uh one at a time the
story evolves
quickly by episode two
uh it moves into uh what is the present
day for the story because the prologue
takes place ahead of that and uh things
start to move really fast and the music
gets faster cool
so uh we're going to be releasing an
episode maybe every six weeks um and so
we do need a little help financially
getting that out there and done
i think we're gonna do it it's just a
matter of who's gonna be
who's gonna help
so it's gonna get done and then when
it's done we're gonna release the the
full film
as one entire cohesive unit uh but it's
also an album if it's yeah okay i keep
forgetting to talk about the music
because the music is old because the
music is all original music that you're
writing for the movie yeah yeah so i i
did with this video i'll take over the
intro like i do last time on the channel
with something i've done so that's the
best score from the film and uh yeah
we've got new music so there's going to
be a single at least one single released
uh song or two released with every
episode oh wow okay so that's how it's
going to do yeah that's great it'll be a
full record when the movie comes out
it'll be you know 60 minutes of music
that's done so um not a like more
instrumental content than normal and i'm
not sure how much of that i'll put on
the final record depending on how strong
it is or um on its own without the
visual so one of our things about
scoring for people out there that do
music and want to score because scoring
is like a real like ooh like a real
alluring business for people
um is that it's weird once you put
music's not the same as when you're
making music just to listen as music and
music to accompany a film
because the film does a lot of the work
like if there are a lot of shows where i
was like oh this is great and then i
pull the stuff out like the mandalorians
one of them like i love the original
star wars scores and the and the
mandalorians cool but then when i pull
it out by itself and listen to it next
to a john williams piece i'm like well
dude not fair to the composer to compare
to john williams uh but
it's like um
it's like oh like this is not he
actually there's not a ton happening
it's just kind of textured and slightly
small amounts of a lot of content
um so yeah that's an important thing for
people who want to get into scoring or
even if you're like someone who never
pays attention to the score start paying
attention to it and figure out what you
like and what you don't like uh it's
it's an interesting world um but yeah
it's it's some of the stuff has to
it can't be your most
like best thing to listen to by itself
it's going to accompany the image and
serve the image
but you have you have some songs with uh
with words and i think it's not just
music yeah oh yeah yeah absolutely um
so uh we'll have a lyric video that
comes out a few days so this video
hopefully airs on the day of the episode
in the episode
comes out november 16th at 9 00 pm
and uh it's the prologue to the bigger
story so uh that's on our youtube
channel which we're poor robins you can
find us pretty easily and you know like
and subscribe smash that like button um
so i'm just going to spend the rest of
the talk here advertising my channel
no i think it's great i think people
have to i think people have to uh to
check it out and uh you know you know
leave comments of course and uh yeah i
think just understand that this is
really this is something that we're
hoping to see flower you know both neil
and i we've been talking in private for
years by now you got to meet in person
this year yeah that's right we actually
did in florida it does exist everyone
people are starting to wonder if you
exist yeah we actually have legs you
know like uh
[Laughter]
but we're really hoping that that you
know these little gestures we're posing
is just also going to be impetus for
other people people that are watching
these people that are
that are getting excited also about
these this returning to kind of good
stories and so uh so we're excited to
see where it goes and we hope that that
other artists other storytellers
uh get involved and you know and i
you know and if you're also if you're a
professional artist and yeah a lot of
people i've been in contact with risa if
you're a professional artist if you're a
musician if you're a a painter or an
illustrator or a filmmaker you know
reach out because we're we're kind of uh
yeah we're building up to some
interesting stuff and we're excited to
have at least people have a buzz around
around what's going on and
and uh and who knows where this is going
to lead who knows i think eventually
there's going to be it just seems like
it's heading that way there's going to
be a collective of people that are doing
quality and people that want to learn to
do quality and
uh work and and lead up to that also
like here i'll hijack jonathan's channel
for a second i really think he needs to
do an online symbolic world conference
um with you know some of the characters
from his avengers universe in there um
the other people he has on his channel
uh if you think that's a good idea like
someone comment that and like it and let
him know that a symbolic world
conference online would be a terrific
idea and you would be glad to attend
all right okay neil so
all right so we're all helping each
other all right everybody so so thanks
for your attention you know check out
the queen of the night and everything
else dirt poor robbins is doing like i
said uh their last album dead horse is
really like just one of my favorite
albums i listen to it all the time uh
and my kids love it too my daughter they
all have they all have the merch and
they they love to to
to uh make help their friends discover
uh their band so so check it out and uh
and stay tuned for more discussion with
neil in the future and also
um you know like we said who knows where
this is going to lead we might be
surprised uh to find out where all of
this is going so thanks everybody for
your time talk to you very soon again
bye-bye